-One person
puts on their headphones
with loud music playing.
The other person then picks up
a card, okay?
Here's the stack of cards here,
and there's a random phrase
on the card, okay?
I'll be the first person to go.
The person
wearing the headphones
has to try to guess
what I just said, okay?
And you guess
until you get one right,
then we'll switch it up.
The other person puts on the
headphones and tries to guess.
-It's a...
It's a contest.
Like, keeping points
or something?
-What?
-It's just something stupid
we're doing,
or is it, like, you keep score?
-It's just fun.
Everyone's having a good time.
-Stupid.
♪♪
-Fun, for once.
[ As Blake ] I just want to
keep score, and what the heck.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't hear anything.
-I know, thank God.
Thank God you couldn't, yeah.
-I said I can't hear anything.
-Yeah, I can hear you.
I'm not wearing headphones.
I can --
Alright, here's the first one.
Ready?
-Did you do it?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
Pumpkin spice latte.
-Say it one more time.
[ Laughter ]
-My pee-pee's stressed out?
-[ Laughter ]
-Come on, man!
That's not even close
to the word!
Try again.
[ Laughter ]
-My pee-pee...
I know it's, "My pee-pee."
[ Laughter ]
I swear to God, this is --
What is this?
-Stop yelling at me!
Let's try it one more time.
-One more time.
-Alright,
I'll take that as a win.
That counts.
-Did I get it?
Pumpkin spice latte.
-Alright, here we go.
I'm gonna try it now.
Here we go.
-This is the stupidest thing,
literally,
I have been a part of
in my entire career.
-Alright, go, go.
I can't hear you.
-You can't hear.
That is so loud.
I don't -- I don't even know
how to say this.
Okay.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
[ Laughter ]
-Billy Eisner compromises.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Benedict Cumberbatch.
-Benedict Cumberbatch.
I knew that was it. That was it!
That was good!
No, we're playing together!
-There is no way.
-Yeah, I swear.
That was great.
-That doesn't even
mean anything.
-That's a human --
he's nominated for an Oscar.
-Who?
-Yes!
Put your headphones on.
-That's a person?
-Get out of the house, man.
-I've never even heard of that.
-Here we go.
He's a very famous actor.
Very famous actor.
-Bull crap.
-Alright, here we go.
Oh, boy. Uh...
"Cobra Kai."
-Show me the gnocchis.
[ Laughter ]
-"Cobra Kai."
-One more time.
[ Laughter ]
-Sh...
Show me...
-Don't say, "Tennokies," again,
man.
Cobra...
[ Laughter ]
-Cobra!
-Kai.
-Karate! Cobra karate!
-Close enough, close enough.
-Did I get it?
Did I get it?
-"Cobra Kai."
Ever seen "Karate Kid"?
Forget it.
It stars Benedict Cumberbatch
and Ralph Macchio.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
Last one. Here we go.
-What?
These are the dumbest phrases.
I know this one.
"50 Shades of Grey."
-"50 Shades of Grey"!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're a good pronunciator.
Blake and I are
about to go head-to-head
in a game of
Caramel Apple Roulette.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-[ Coughing, laughing ]
-What is it?
-Hey, there he is.
-Yes, Jimmy.
Here...would appear
to be 12 caramel apples.
-Okay.
-But don't be fooled!
Eight of these are apples.
Four are raw onions.
[ Audience ohhs ]
You and Blake will take turns
taking one caramel apple
and taking a bite.
You won't know which are apples
and which are onions!
But once you choose an apple --
-What the hell are you doing?
-I don't know.
Everything's off today.
Once you choose an apple, you
must take a bite and swallow it.
No put-backs!
First one to bite
into two onions loses!
Blake, as guest of the show,
you will choose
the first caramel apple.
-This is the dumbest thing.
Yeah.
-Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Which one?
-Which are apples?
-Am I choosing right now?
-Yeah. Which are onions?
Which are apples?
That one looks good.
-That one looks like an apple.
-That looks like
a Texakoma apple.
-You know what?
I'm calling bull crap on you.
-Good luck!
-Now wait a minute.
If this is an onion, do I lose,
or I get another chance?
-No, you get two onions!
[ Cackles evilly ]
-[ Laughs ] Go for it, man.
Just take a bite and have faith.
-I'm only here 'cause
Seth Meyers was booked.
-Yeah, I understand.
Thank you. I know. I heard.
It's an onion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Blake, I'm so happy you're here.
[ Laughs ]
-Good luck!
-Alright.
-Which are apples --
-I'm not going to sell one album
off this stupid crap.
No one cares about this.
-♪ Ba-da, ba-da, ba-da,
bahp, bahp ♪
♪ Happy Halloween, dude ♪
♪ Happy Hallo -- ♪
It feels a little heavy.
It feels like an apple.
I feel good. I'm confident.
Pretty confident dude.
Things are going great.
-That's a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's more like it!
-Ohh!
-Now we got some drama!
It's like the
World Series, buddy!
1-1.
Yeah!
-Caramelized onions.
That's disgusting.
How did you swallow this?
-Stop fingering everything.
What are you doing?
What is it? What are you doing?
-Right.
-Was it good?
-Oh, it's disgusting.
Uh, Blake, pick that one.
-No, that didn't work.
-Oh, come on. That guy.
-Ooh!
-Ohh!
[ Cackles evilly ]
[ Laughter ]
-1-1. It's like
the World Series.
Good luck.
Go get 'em.
Feels like an apple.
Ohh! [ Laughs ]
That is the game!
Ladies and gentlemen!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you for coming.
Congrats on the record.
-Thank you.
-You just finished your tour
on St. Patrick's Day in Philly.
-We did a -- my tour
was 15 shows for the year.
-That's fantastic.
How did you make that deal?
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't make the deal.
I just -- that's what we did.
We didn't have time
because of "The Voice."
So I don't have time to tour
like I used to.
-[ Southern accent ]
I'm talking about time, yeah.
-So then we --
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes
you have to make time.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just saying --
-We got it the first time.
[ Laughter ]
-But I said it a second time.
-No, but we ended
on St. Patrick's Day.
Thought that'd be a good,
fun way to blow it out.
-[ Normal voice ]
In Philly, too.
-In Philly.
-How was that --
[ People cheering ]
How was that crowd?
-They're pretty excited
in that town still.
-Yeah.
-They're still freaking out.
-That's right. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-The Roots are from Philly.
They're still freaking out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And my team -- my team
is the Arizona Cardinals,
which I thought I could
get up there, and be like
"Man, I'm an Arizona fan."
Even though you all just won
the freaking Super Bowl,
they're like, "Boo, you suck!"
[ Laughter ]
-They don't stop, man.
-I know we suck.
What do you mean? You guys won.
You won!
-I know, man. Do you --
when you're backstage,
because I walked
by your dressing room,
I didn't hear -- do you do,
like, vocal warmups and stuff?
-[ Chuckling ] No.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you like --
♪ Me me me me me ♪
something like
♪ Oom, la, la-la-la? ♪
-Did you really walk by my
dressing room to see if I was
doing something in there like
that? I don't know, dude.
-Yeah, I kind of, yeah --
I just wanted to check.
You wouldn't speak to me
before the show.
That's why,
so I just wanted to --
[ Laughter ]
I just wanted to see if
I stopped by, maybe see if,
you know -- You're a very nice
guy, but, you know, backstage,
different story, ain't it?
[ Laughter ]
-Why do you make me feel like
Super Dave Osborne
every time I come on this show?
Remember that guy? That's what
you make me feel like.
-I love Super Dave Osborne.
Oh, really?
-Every time I come on here,
yeah.
-No, I love --
You know I love you.
-I know, but I have a drink
before the show.
That's what I do to warm up.
I have a drink.
I have a vodka, and a --
-Vodka and what --
What is your drink?
We had sake before.
-Yeah, we did have
the rice wine.
-Rice wine.
-Rice wine, that's what we had.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I like a vodka, and like a,
you know, Sprite Zero,
or diet Sierra Mist.
7-Up.
-Really?
-Something citrusy. Yeah.
-Yeah, I like that.
No way.
-Do you like that?
-Well, no, I like the idea
of you doing that.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I don't -- I don't
like that at all.
No. I would go -- I would go
more with like a gin and tonic
myself, or a vodka tonic.
-Okay.
Hey, you remember this dude?
[ Laughter, audience "oohs" ]
[ Audience cheering ]
Look at this guy.
How old were you there?
How old was this stud
right here?
How old is this guy?
Was this high school?
-I believe I was -- Oh, yeah.
I think I was 16
in that picture.
-Wow. And you -- did you always
want to be a country singer,
or did you want to -
-Don't act like you had
a serious question to ask me.
[ Laughter ]
Just so you could have a reason
to show that damn picture
on television.
[ Laughter ]
-If I could, I would have it
printed on a t-shirt.
-I know, I know. You're like,
"Oh, well, tell me,
did you really
want to be a singer?"
[ Laughter ]
Jackass.
-Oh, my God.
You didn't have a question
to ask me.
-You can't call me a jackass!
-You did not have one question
to ask me.
You just wanted to show
the picture.
-No, I want to know,
like, what did you dream about?
[ Laughter ]
What were you dreaming about
when you were this age?
No, because you know what?
I do research on you.
Every time you come on,
you act like I don't know
who I'm talking to.
I know who you are.
I know you played basketball
in high school,
and I know that you had
a nickname called,
like, "Hook-shot" Shelton.
-I didn't actually
play basketball
for the team in high school.
I just -- we would play
sometimes, you know,
after school,
and I gave myself the name
"Hook-shot" Shelton.
[ Laughter ]
Because I could do it.
That's the one way you
can shoot the ball
and be running away
at the same time.
-That was my move, too.
I would foul somebody
with this hand,
and then hook-shot
with this hand.
-Really?
-So I would dribble, I'd run up,
and I'd hit them with this one,
I would swat them away,
and then hook-shot.
I wanted to see if you
still got game, so --
Would you like to try?
-Oh, you're damn right I will.
Watch this.
Ready?
-Yeah.
-Hey, play one of them made-up
songs that don't exist.
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Here we go.
-"Hook-shot" Shelton!
-Ready?
-[Whistling musically]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what friends
are for, man.
-Yeah, you moved it for me
a little bit.
-A little bit,
I helped you out, man.
-I appreciate it.
Thank you for the help.
That's the first nice thing
you've ever done for me.
-That's not true at all.
-On your show.
-And we've -- Dude,
let's talk about "The Voice."
'Cause you have Kelly Clarkson,
a new addition.
But you've known her
for a while.
-I've known Kelly
for literally years.
-She's fantastic.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Literally --
-Many years.
-Many a year.
Adam Levine, you've known
for literally --
-Way longer than I've known
Adam, I've known Kelly.
-You invited them to your house
on New Year's, didn't you?
Your ranch?
-Several years ago, yeah.
This is like -- New Year's
of like 2012 or something.
Because he was playing --
Adam was playing.
There's a casino there nearby
where I live in Oklahoma,
and they had the New Year's gig,
and so we all went over there,
and Kelly was still living
down in Texas.
So I was, "Kelly, come up here,
we're gonna --
let's go watch Adam,
we'll make fun of him."
[ Laughter ]
-Is it true that --
Is it true that -- is it true
that Adam cried that night?
-Yeah, so what happened --
[ Laughter ]
-It's the best story.
-We had a designated driver
because it was New Year's Eve.
-Yep, sure.
-And we were drinking.
-You went for it.
-Yeah.
And, so, we went to his show,
made fun of him,
and then when he got done,
he came to stay at my house
with me for a couple of days.
-Yeah.
-And on the way back
from the casino to my place,
we got pulled over.
We was in, like, a van.
This guy that we had rented
a van, and the driver,
and this guy, we got
pulled over by, like,
a deputy sheriff, or whatever.
And not that we don't respect
the police...
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-...but we knew we hadn't
done anything wrong,
and so you can be a little
cockier, you know,
at that point.
-Where were you --
-We got a designated driver.
Why are you pulling us over?
And Adam didn't see it that way
because Adam
is from Los Angeles,
where you don't talk back
to the police.
-Yeah.
-And in Oklahoma,
if you've got a good point,
you do sometimes, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And so Kelly, you know --
And especially Kelly.
I mean,
she was ribbing this guy.
-Oh, really?
-He had a mustache
that wasn't cool-looking.
[ Laughter ]
And Adam -- And Adam was --
began to --
he was convinced
we were going to jail.
[ Laughter ]
And he got upset. He did.
I will never forget it.
He was like, "Kelly, shut up!
[ Voice breaking ]
Kelly, shut up!"
You know, and it was like,
it got intense.
-I can't wait to have Adam --
-And thanks for bringing up
that story, 'cause now I really
am going to get pulled over
and get a ticket in Oklahoma.
-No, you won't. No, you won't.
-Can I please just sing my song?
-I love the song, by the way.
This is track 11 on the record.
It's the last song
on the record.
"I Lived It." Makes me cry.
The song makes me sad.
-Does it really?
-Yeah, man.
[ Sniffles ] It does.
[ Laughter ]
All the memories of growing up
and you got --
Life is an amazing thing.
-I mean, what is it about
specifically,
lyrically about this song
that makes you cry,
that makes you upset?
-I think of my own life.
-But what lyric in the song...
[ Laughter ]
...is the one that really
takes you down?
-Oh, oh, there's so many.
There's so many lyrics.
[ Laughter ]
That's the thing about the song.
It's almost too much song,
you know?
My only wish was that, you know,
it was shorter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Too much for me to handle.
No, I like -- I tell you what.
The Crisco line.
-The Crisco line, okay.
-Yeah, Yellow Jackets.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, yeah, that's right.
I know the song.
-Where's your cue --
[ Laughter ]
-There's no cue cards.
-There's a cue card.
-This is called real life, dude.
-Okay, you do know it, okay.
I take it back.
I stand corrected.
-Yeah, I tell you every time
you come on, I am a fan.
I really enjoy your work.
-My girlfriend is going to
break up with me tonight
because of this show.
[ Laughter ]
-I know, I know.
-So anything you do nice
from this point on,
you can kiss my ass.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show everyone a clip
of the family-friendly show,
"The Voice."
Here is Blake Shelton
from tomorrow night's episode.
Take a look.
-And, Kelsey, I know that you've
been dealing with difficulties
of what it takes to sing
long, long hours.
You're so excited,
you can't sleep,
and, you know, there's all
these things like you wish
you could shut your mind down.
-That happens to all of us.
-Doesn't happen to Blake,
though.
[ Laughter ]
-What did he say?
-Oh, no.
-I feel like he said,
[ As Billy Idol ]
"White wedding,"
but I'm not sure.
I couldn't hear it.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly my point.
-♪ Nice day for a ♪ Sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Blake Shelton, everybody!
Tomorrow night,
the Green Bay Packers
and the Seattle Seahawks
kick off the NFL season
at 7:30 p.m. right here on NBC.
In honor of that, Blake and I
are going head-to-head
in a game
of Random Object Football Toss.
Now, we're gonna take turns
trying to complete passes
of random objects
into that target right there.
Now, each object
is worth one point.
That was me in high school.
-Holy crap.
I'm not gonna make that.
-That's our high school.
Yeah, you can make that.
Each object is worth one point.
The last object, the moneyball,
is worth two.
High score wins.
Let's take a look
at what we're shooting.
Mannequin head.
[ Laughter ]
Foot-long sub.
Beer pitcher full of peanuts.
Seven -- no, eight-layer dip.
And the moneyball,
worth two points.
[ As Blake ]
♪ And some neon lights ♪
[ Normal voice ]
It's a bullhorn.
Was that close?
-This is the dumbest thing.
-Alright, welcome, Blake.
We'll edit that all out.
Roots, a little music.
Blake, you go first.
Start from this line
and go for it, buddy.
-What do I go with first?
-Mannequin head.
-Alanis Morissette. Here we go.
-That's not Alanis Morissette.
-Looks like
Alanis Morissette's head.
-That's not
-Okay. Here we go.
Wait a minute,
I don't have a good grip.
-Hut, hut, hike!
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-This is bullcrap!
-No, stop it!
-You've been practicing.
-I'm not practicing.
-This is your studio.
This is your house.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-Don't boo me.
Throw a mannequin head
into a hole.
Oh, really?!
♪♪
This afternoon, no,
you shouldn't have eaten that.
No, that's candle wax.
Sorry about that.
[ Laughter ]
That's a wax sub.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-Piece of it went in there.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-Beer pitcher full of peanuts.
-Which makes perfect sense,
by the way.
♪♪
-Yeah, there you go, man.
There he is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at that.
Oh, nice pass!
-That's right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
-You're good. Thank you.
Thank you for putting
your nuts in my hand.
Appreciate it.
[ Laughter ]
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-You realize this is your show?
-No, I know, I know, I know!
Just hurry up and get on, now.
Seven --
eight-layer bean deep.
It's actually called
seven, comma,
eight-layer bean dip.
-Here we go. Ready?
-Yeah. Go for it.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Hey, come on!
[ Laughs ]
-What is this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-Alright, if you make this,
you win the whole thing,
but if you lose and then
I make mine, I'll win.
It's worth two points.
Moneyball,
moneyball, moneyball.
[ Laughter ]
♪ It's a moneyball ♪
♪ It's my 12th album
called "Moneyball" ♪
♪ It's "Moneyball" ♪
♪ Everybody loves
a good moneyball ♪
♪ I said, hand me your nuts ♪
♪ We're gonna play a game ♪
♪ Oh, moneyball ♪
[ Laughs ] It's a good song.
You should think about it.
-You realize this is your show.
You don't have to air
any of this.
There's still time
to edit this out.
-Thank you.
-Okay.
-Yeah, good luck.
Best of luck, there, Blake.
-Do it right here.
I think I got this figured out.
-Yeah. Oh, really?
-Watch this.
-Go for it.
-I like that.
-This is for
the Arizona Cardinals.
-That's the first thing
that I do. I like that.
Here we go. Ready?
-Ooh.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh, man, that was close.
-I like that.
I like that tactic.
-Bullcrap!
-Alright, stop it!
Now, Blake, calm down!
And a onesie, and a twosie...
-What are you doing?!
That's my method!
-...and a threesie,
and a foursie,
fivesie...
Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
I forgot to let go.
Alright, one-nothing,
the winner,
Blake Shelton, everybody!